[Musique]
bon alors les gars c'est quoi la base du
water-polo piscine
voilà pourquoi
non mais c'est quoi son problème c'est
sa méthode vincent oui quand on est à l'
attaque et que le dmi fait une traversée
les coéquipiers font quoi ben ali ils
collent leurs défenseurs non il se
décale tous d'un poste pour déstabiliser
le bloc mardi
bon alors c'est quoi la meilleure façon
de faire un pressing fred
c'est quoi la meilleure façon de faire
un pressing le nettoyage à sec si vous
voulez réussir dans le water-polo
vous devez avoir l'endurance d'un
marathonien la puissance d'un rugbyman
la précision d'un golfeur et la
concentration ce qui est le truc le plus
compliqué pour vous d'un joueur d'échecs
ok on est pas dans la merde pour comment
sunshine stars sont comme tout un
[Musique]
hôpital et sa valeur
rina et runa ça me tabih malade
imaginaire myspace palais i'm looking
for good time boys boys boys et chérif
au malade
super la carrière est finie ma film
parle plus et je suis dans le trou du
cul de l'allemagne est qu une bande
d'ados de la famille céline dion on
n'est pas les seuls à voir des problèmes
qui sait et c'est quoi le problème peut
dire la couleur de leur robe
[Musique]
tu vois vincent il ya six mois quand les
gens sans village ont compris qu'ils
préféraient les garçons il a dû faire à
paris j'étais vite les détails cédric il
a réussi à fonder une famille mais comme
beaucoup de jeunes papas y trouve pas sa
place
dames et elle est abandonnée à la
naissance et depuis huit ans c'est un
peu nous sa famille fred elle se
débrouille pas mal mais elle est une
femme dans un corps d'homme et depuis
qu'elle a fait sa transition tout le
monde la regarde comme une bête curieuse
alors que joël on regarde de moins en
moins et plus il vieillit plus il est
aigri
et alexis s'est fait briser le coeur
ne comprend pas qu'il doit passer à
autre chose et xavier obama via par une
chaude pisse de temps en temps et les
problèmes on les surmonte mais chacun sa
façon
ok
et était gentille mais je vois pas
comment je pourrais surmonté de pas
faire les mondiaux
tout ça parce que ma fille dé me prends
quoi pour un et un saloon aux folles a
mais pas du tout homophobes mathias
était juste un peu con tu te remercie
t'es gentil je dois jouer